salut les épis curieuses et les épis
curieux vous l'aimez comment vous votre
café long court allongé r trèô avec ou
sans sucre après l'eau c'est la boisson
la plus consommée dans le monde 90 % des
Français comp fait ce qu'ils en
raffolent boire du café estil vraiment
bon pour la santé est-ce que ça empêche
vraiment de dormir comme on le dit allez
je vous raconte tout et promis ce sera
son
[Musique]
filtre
un chiffre pour commencer 2,6 milliards
c'est le nombre de tasses de café qui
sont bu chaque jour à travers le monde
deux habitants sur TR en consomme sur la
planète sous différentes formes café
turc espressoou café filtre ce qui en
fait la marchandise la plus exportée
juste derrière le pétrole pas étonnant
qu'on qualifie de nouvell hornoir les
Français en raffolent et pourtant nous
sommes loin d'être les plus gros bueurs
de café dans le monde ce sont sont les
finlandais Caracol en tête avec 7,4 kg
de café par an et par personne en 2e et
3e position on trouve les Néerlandais et
les Suédois qui consomment environ 7 kg
de café par an et par personne avant de
vous dire si le café empêche ou non de
dormir il faut d'abord que je vous
raconte l'incroyable épopée de cette
boisson on produit du café dans 90 pays
beaucoup en Amérique centrale et en
Amérique du Sud et pourtant le café
n'est pas originaire de cette région du
monde il vient même d'un autre continent
d'Afrique on dit qu'un berger éthiopien
aurait découvert le café par hasard
grâce à ses chèvres alors qu'il
promenait son troupeau il aurait
constaté que ces bêtes s'agitaai et
dansaient après avoir mangé les fruits
du caféer c'est une légende toutefois
c'est bien en Éthiopie que l'idée de
consommer la graine de café aurait germé
les toutes premières traces écrites
concernant le café datent du 9e siècle
on y fait allusion à ses effets
vivifiants et son rôle facilitant la
digestion les fouilles récentes laissent
supposer qu'à la préhistoire le café
faisait déjà partie de l'alimentation
des habitants de cette région ce sont
les Arabes qui à partir du 15e siècle
vont développer la culture du cafayer à
travers tout le Proche-Orient et la
péninsule arabique ils ont aussi l'idée
de toréfier les grain là-bas on
l'appelle Kawa un mot yiménite qui
signifie revigorant au fil des ans et
des voyages le mot se transforme il
devient cavet en Turquie cafille en
Chine au Danemark c'est café avec un cas
en italien café et Coffi en anglais un
mot aux consonants identiques d'une
langue à l'autre en Europe il faut
attendre le 17e siècle pour que le café
fasse son apparition sur les tables et
pour cause les Arabes veillent au grain
c'est ça ils vont quand même pas tuer la
poule aux odor ils interdisent les
exportations de plants et même de
graines ils ne vendent aux Européens que
des grains gris autrement dit des grains
ébouillantés de vieux grains pas assez
frais pour germer et donner des arbustes
mais en 1616 des marchands hollandais
parviennent à leur dérober quelques
plans de café et comme le cafayer a
besoin de chaleur et d'humidité c'est
dans leur colonie en Indonésie qu'ils
vont le planter devant le succès de
l'opération les Anglais font la même
chose et voilà comment des caféers
atterrissent en Inde une colonie
britannique à ce stade de l'histoire il
n'y a toujours pas de café sur le
continent américain mais iloche en 1714
la ville d'Amsterdam offre un plan de
cafayer à Louis XIV souverain français
apprécie cette boisson le cafayer est
planté sous serre il fructifie mais pour
produire les fameux grains il faut un
climat plus adapté que celui de la
métropole alors comme l'ont fait les
voisins la France transfèt de jeunes
pouss de caféer sous les tropiques en
ses colonies vers la Martinique d'abord
puis la Guadeloupe Saint-Domingue et la
Guyane et ça marche le café devient une
boisson à la mode à la cour et dans
Paris des maisons du café s'ouvrent dans
la capitale dont le fameux Procop qui
existe toujours grâce à ces plantations
la France deviendra même un temps le
premier producteur de café du monde les
Espagnols et les Portugais installés en
Amérique centrale et en Amérique du Sud
non loin des Antilles donc comprennent
alors les bénéfices qu'ils pourraient
eux aussi tirer de la production du café
personne ne voulant leur encéder il
décide donc de voler des caféers au
français et les plant dans leur colonie
la plante trouve des conditions idéales
et sa culture s'étend sur un immense
territoire au fil des siècles elle va
devenir l'une des cultures emblématiques
de toute cette région du monde
aujourd'hui 90 pays produisent au total
10000 tonnes de café par an la plus
grande partie en Amérique du Sud et en
Amérique centrale le Brésil arrivant sur
la première marche du podium avec 30 %
de la production mondiale selon la
plupart des experts le meilleur café du
monde serait produit sur l'île de la
Réunion en France donc dans l'océan
Indien il porte un très joli nom Le
Bourbon Pointu Bourbon pour l'île
Bourbon ancien nom de l'île de la
Réunion pointu à cause de la forme de
son
fruit regardez ces belles ceris ça donne
envie hein et pourtant elles n'ont pas
vocation à être consommé enfin pas sous
cette forme ce sont les cerises du
cafayer cet arbuste tropical peut faire
jusqu'à 5 m de hauteur ces cerises
charnues sont pourvu d'un noyau qui est
divisé en deux parties les fameux grains
de café l'obtention des grains est une
opération assez complexe il faut d'abord
retirer la peau la pulpe et ensuite
l'enveloppe qui recouvre les grains ce
qu'on appelle la parche il n'y a qu'un
endroit dans le monde où il n'y a rien à
faire en Thaïlande les grains sont
récoltés directement dans des crottes
d'éléphants le pachiderme se nourrit des
branches de cafayer mais il ne digère
pas le noyau des cerises Bur mais c'est
dégoûtant il faut croire que non ça
donne un café très goûteux dont
paraît-il on se souvient pendant
longtemps peut-être aussi à cause de son
prix jusqu'à 2300 € le kilg une fois
extrait les grains de café n'ont aucune
odeur les arôes sont piégés à
l'intérieur pour les libérer le café
doit être toréfié c'est-à-dire chauffé
et grillé la palette aromatique du café
est très importante plus importante que
celle du vin on compte jusqu'à 800
arômes différents contre 5 à 600 pour le
vin cette fois il ne reste plus qu'à le
moudre et j'en viens à la question du
départ le café nous tient-il éveillé le
mot est peut-être un peu fort mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'après avoir avalé
un café on ressent comme un coup de
fouet on est prêt à démarrer de nouveau
au quart de tour c'est à cause de la
caféine identifié pour la première fois
dans le café cette molécule est présente
dans une soixantaine de plantes le thé
le maté même le chocolat cette molécule
a pour effet de stimuler le système
nerveux c'est pour cette raison que
notre rythme cardiaque accélère parfois
après avoir consommé du café elle freine
également l'accumul tion d'adénosine
dans le cerveau il s'agit d'une molécule
chargée de signaler l'état de fatigue à
l'organisme c'est pourquoi nous avons le
sentiment que le café nous réveille nous
empêche de dormir c'est donc ça pour
faire la sieste mieux vaut prendre un
long et bien non s'ils sont plus forts
en goût les expresso ne sont pas les
plus riches en caféine la dose de
caféine dépend du temps de contact entre
la mouture c'est-à-dire le café moulu et
l'eau or plus le café est mer plus ce
contact avec l'eau et long par ailleurs
la caféine n'agit pas tout de suite il
faut attendre environ 30 minutes ensuite
il faut entre 4 à 6 he pour que
l'organisme en élimine 50 %. 10 à 12 he
après l'ingjestion il peut donc en
rester jusqu'à 25 % résultat si vous
buvez un petit café sur les coups de 17h
et bien à 23h il vous restera environ 25
mg de caféine dans le sang vous risquez
donc d'avoir un peu de mal à vous
endormir du coup pour pour éviter les
insomnies il est conseillé d'arrêter de
boire du café 6 he au moins avant
d'aller vous coucher plutôt c'est encore
mieux l'Agence européenne pour la
sécurité des médicaments recommande aux
adultes de ne pas dépasser 400 mg de
caféine par jour soit l'équivalent de
trois café filtres ou quatre expresso si
vous respectez ces recommandations le
café ne devrait pas vous empêcher de
dormir mieux il vous fera du bien car le
café a des vertus que vous ne soupçonnez
peut-être pas la café a notamment une
action
vasoconstrictrice autrement dit elle
favorise la contraction des vaisseaux
sanguins la caféine permet de diminuer
l'inflammation des vaisseaux voilà
pourquoi un café peut parfois soulager
une migraine des études récentes ont
aussi montré que boire TR à qu tasses de
café par jour réduirait le risque
d'infarctus du myocarde de 12 % et le
risque d'AVC de 8 à 13 %. plus
surprenant encore 3 à 5 tasses de café
par jour diminuerait le risque de
développer un diabète de type 2 mais là
il s'agit que
d'hypothèse du coup je vais reprendre
une petite tasse de café
[Musique]
moi voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous
a plu et qu'elle vous a donné envie de
partager un bon café entre amis en
attendant n'hésitez pas à liker et à
nous suggérer d'autres idées en
commentaire à très
[Musique]
bientôt